hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember Christmas Christmas Christmas
Christmas Christmas Christmas hey ever
mention yet that I love Christmas I do I
love Christmas the absolute best time of
the year even this job that forces me to
watch the worst of Christmas can't
possibly make me hate this wonderful
holiday even when I see things like I'm
the ghost of Christmas future the ghost
of Christmas future yes the ghost of
Christmas future I'm here to show you
what happens if you don't start enjoying
Christmas but I do enjoy Christmas Wow
yeah I love it I'm all over it
you've absolutely no reason for
Christmas know what favorite time of the
year all right all right guy don't think
you understand quite how this works
every comedy show does a Christmas carol
parody usually around Christmas well not
me I don't want I've got these three
other ghosts waiting there on retainer
it's just too much I don't care
ah think of the possibilities the
psychics the puns think of the cameos
look I'm not doing anything Christmas
Carol related anyway I'm doing babes in
toyland
paintin toyrap the Disney flick no no no
this one was made in the 80s 1986 to be
exact it has half the talent and half
the creativity and definitely half the
effort
it's about as cheap as a musical
knockoff can get and just to make things
even better it stars a young drew
Barrymore in a young Keanu Reeves who
you say you love Christmas now rific but
wait until you see this Kandi Koated
abomination don't worry critic well
let's get started we start off with some
van Gogh snow and observe some of the
slowest moving shoppers in mall history
as we see our hero named Lisa played by
Drew Barrymore a post crack I think why
else would she choose this role she's
excited because as her sisters getting
ready to go to work she starts building
up what she got her for Christmas I got
you a great present don't ask what it is
it's a surprise
I bet snoop under well then what is it
wait wonder was a real guest god this
must be the most boring family to have
Christmas with oh boy I can't wait to
see what it is Wow it's a box so she
puts on her raincoat for the snow Lisa
gets concerned because of the weather
report
and here's Gayle with an update as of
10:00 p.m. the giant Canadian storm
continues to surge its way south they're
calling it hurricane canook
so Lisa decides it's too dangerous for
her sister to work tonight and tries to
go get her
there's Bill & Ted's Excellent Kwanzaa
how about a quick Christmas Pizza
Capone's before I drop you home
yeah I don't think I could eat through a
fence oh here we go again the Delilah of
the five-and-dime we we thank you for
this bountiful performance we're about
to receive Mary listen what you're doing
here sorry I tried to call but the
kranji down there you gotta come home
right away
someone should tell Bryan Kocis to hear
from your big chance
uh-uh now that's a key a new moment huh
I'm sure in the script it was written I
do not wish to partake in conversations
with that man - which Keano translated
it as uh-huh as opposed to his cha Oh
doing your job is pleasing me which in
your case will not be difficult you know
what I mean
no I don't you know for a smart-looking
girly really pretty dumb don't you know
it's better business to be nice to the
boss don't you talk Mary like that what
the heck is that
another great delivery to go in the
acting books what the heck is that
though to be fair I think we'll all be
saying that line a lot throughout this
movie
oh yeah well with your attitude you can
be out of here real quick you know that
your attitude I could be out of here
right now there's a blizzard out there
but I'm gonna take my baby sister home
Mary I know I know you're not a baby
you're lagging years old thanks for that
come on Lisa let me go find Jack I feel
like that ruin my biggest one-day pick
it it wouldn't raise it I can't stop
doing my Rodney Dangerfield impression
you know respect no respect at all
oh my god
surely the eleven-year-old girl who I've
never met before knows exactly what
she's talking about the PA everybody fee
Merry Christmas
hey that'd be funny if one of those
balls actually hit him so Leif starts
driving everybody home which is weird
seeing how they clearly walked to work
and they said on and on the roads were
dangerous and they can't help but sing a
song about their charming little city I
come from the iron beyond and Cincinnati
Ohio
USA at first they called me but since
Indians on Eddie what the heck is that
but even God has had it what they're
singing and tries to smoke them by tree
so in the beard is transition to a
magical lamb lisa falls out of the car
slides down a hill on her sled and bumps
into a tree picture CS lewis was
watching this shouting kill i knew i
could have made that weirder
so as you probably picked up tweet lane
looks less like an enchanted kingdom and
more like one of those bad Bible themed
amusement parks like Christian corners
or Jehova's Wonderland but I never know
in any way
yeah it's a world so enchanted that
animals don't even need to blink or move
their mouths when they talk it may look
like heinous budget cuts but it's all
part of the magical experience what the
heck is back I'm Georgie Porgie and she
paced her at the Toyland cookie factory
Hey here have a a raspberry ripple wow
look at all the powdered sugar that's
not powdered sugar I'm going to a
wedding what's so terrible about going
to a wedding
excuse me I thought they were supposed
to be fine not this one who my best
friend Jack sweetheart Mary is about to
marry that terrible me no you'd go
Barnaby but she really loves Jack he'll
see the house on the hill the bowling
ball know where that's Barnaby's house
sometimes when he gets really angry he
rolls his house right down the street
not two people over like they were nine
pins ah that is really weird
no your remote-control disappearing on
you is weird and living in a bowling
ball is fucking insane ball farming
because Barnaby bought the mortgage on
her mother's house and said he'd throw
them all out the street if she didn't
call mary's to Loyola daughter to let
that happen
and what's even worse Barnaby is Jack's
uncle wait does this guy do anything
outside just shouting exposition now
before we begin watching the Fellowship
of the Ring I think it's only fair to go
through the entire appendix of The Lord
of the Ring trilogy
Aragorn at Arwen's history is a long and
complicated one so as they roam through
the land of fairies they finally come
across Jack who is not happy that Mary
is marrying Barnaby
oh whoa that's Barnaby with his two
goons Zack and wreck but they're so
young and pretty she can't possibly an
area it is picture like that yes for as
we all know all pretty young people are
good and should only marry other pretty
young people and all ugly people deserve
to be shunned and only marry the
leftover feces found in roadkill fuck
with us we Bend a mine school I'm
trapped in a box I'm jammed in a month I
now pronounce you both him do you
sack and she really should be marrying
you so even though she knows absolutely
nothing about those person Lisa tells
Mary not to marry and Barnaby now for
whatever reason is totally helpless to
stop her all he can do is threaten her
with his Clinton phone let's hear it for
Lisa yeah she pointed out the painfully
obvious and it worked for no reason
sorry the other half of us would be
singing if we had the ability to move
our lips mmm this movie make you hate
Christmas yes no I mean it's not good
but doesn't make me hate Christmas look
I don't think you're taking full
advantage of this opportunity the jokes
they just write themselves look ooh it's
the ghost of Christmas fail it's Scout
here go come on let's took me like four
hours in Photoshop go so we could do you
know just putting the name of a magical
place on the side of a barn doesn't make
it a magical place
no seriously honey we're fans Oh cookie
right so Barnaby and the Nosferatu
brothers have an evil scheme they're
going to dump all the cookies down a
trapdoor that I'm shocked they'll be in
the fact we ever noticed before and try
to blame Jack for it
well that's going on this is introduced
to many of the residents in toilet how
dare you not marry that nice rich mr.
Barnaby because I don't love him and you
know perfectly well why not mud I'm
sorry mrs. Howell but did Humpty Dumpty
just die on that wall I don't think he's
breathing oh I've had an idea about that
steak here he's here through this whole
scene and I swear to god he never moves
a muscle just look at his dead eyes you
could totally tell they're not alive in
fact I think you can actually spot the
moment when he leaves our world forever
and there he went
I hope he's handled with care he can't
be easy to bury oh wow a little card
when in Disneyland right the lay mobile
for those of you who think the double
ride is too exciting arrest that man six
months inventory is missing involving
millions many millions of cookies
thousands of boxes of cookies God you
know it doesn't seem very wise to have
an entire cookie based economy it's just
a whole like for Wall Street of this
world was there an Occupy Oreo protest
going on you can't buy the necessities
of life with cookies you can't buy a car
with cookies am i right Jim that's true
so you can't so Jack gets arrested but
his friends managed to break him out
disgustingly easy I would be surprised
if the bars were made of licorice he
could have just chewed his way out thus
they decide to go to the toy master the
ruler of toy land to fix everything the
toy master would never let that happen
he let part of he put jack in jail yeah
but the toy master doesn't know about
that don't you think it's time he did
Wow that's the manliest image I've ever
seen since he-man stepped foot into his
pink Cadillac I'm off to find my dignity
so they go to the toy master played by
mr. Miyagi himself pet marina because
clearly this casting couldn't get any
more surreal Wow he must be a pretty
important person the tour master well
let's put it this way
I don't think Santa Claus would let just
anybody make all the toys for all the
children in the world do you yeah just
like corporate America when Santa's too
lazy to make things himself he hands it
over to the Asians
that's productivity at its best I'm
going to let you in on a little secret
chicken actually very big secret secret
I've never shared with anyone before
what secret oh my god no oh
I've been collecting the evil of the
world you have yes I seek it out
isolated I extract it and I distilled
its essence I seal it in here it also
releases a hot blonde in a midget so
Jack gets the idea to go back to the
cookie factory to search for clues
because of course no authorities would
be at the scene of a crime yeah not CSI
Thailand's best work but Barnaby has a
surprise for him what happened
so Barnaby captures Jack and tells him
all about his evil plan to take over
Thailand I plan to own it and when I do
there'll be some very interesting
changes you want to fuck over my dead
what do you like to fuck not that I
assume your butter any part of your body
was alive but that doesn't seem like a
very good threat Jesus why do they drive
everywhere this place has to be like a
hundred feet long you can hop on one
foot and get there in good time nobody's
ever been inside Barnaby's house before
it could be very dangerous
I'll search it you two stand guard but
wait a min something bizarre Lisa but
it's time I did something besides cry
that's right fuck you scriptwriters this
rolls gonna have some meat Hey
but what a shock going into a bad guys
layer gets her captured too so they go
back to the toy master to seek more
advice don't you have the power to turn
Barnaby into up I'll wind up pussycat or
something oh but what if there's still
some good inside of him there's no good
in Barnaby sir struggle between good and
evil goes on inside of everyone not
Sidney oh man I still think there's good
in the war oh the beautiful flask of
evil evil party you know I may not be an
escape artist
but I think she can't get out of that oh
my god they got me yeah don't you dare
touch a hair on that child child yeah a
child doesn't get choked at age 9 you're
wrong my interfering little since he
what's ADA so he leaves his bird to
gobble them up when he get this
accidentally cuts the ropes whoops
they outwit the creature and try to
figure out what's the best course of
action you enjoyed you must find a way
to get the flask of evil back why us
what well because I'm Holden you are
young and the challenge of protecting
good from evil eventually always
supposed to the young this is how we
protect our traditions
oh yeah this is how you protect your
cowardly ass you lying schmuck
I saw Karate Kid you can wax on wax off
these bozos before happy days comes on
so they think the answers lie in the
forest yes they mistake how many of
these trap doors does this guy have it's
like the Underground Railroad if it was
literally an underground railroad you're
the monster of Toyland Barbie how could
you ever wish Eve on the most wonderful
place ever existed you're insane
well yes that well yes did a pitch for
much of its nuts while reading that line
well yes well yes so he's first to spray
them with gas to turn them Eve
but Lisa is immune because she's from
Cincinnati
why does coming from Cincinnati make you
immune to Cincinnati ones breed evil
toxins all the time that they just
become used to it any chicken wait so
she makes them think they're from
Cincinnati that somehow cures them of
being evil does that make are they
trying to convince us that Cincinnati is
like the one true religion or something
sheesh they're gonna be going to every
door in Toyland proclaiming the word and
if you say the Cincinnati prayer enough
you'll stay away from evil but my lips
look just as much as cosmic damages well
as long as you accept Cincinnati is your
true Lord and Savior everything will be
fine what do you say about that tiny Tom
what okay look look listen tom is a
total guy so if we call a tiny time to
be just like the we lived you coming
exactly like the will of joke yes
but it's Christmas so we'll be forgiven
yeah yeah so the Cincinnati song for
whatever half-baked thought process
keeps them all good and they managed to
escape but Barnaby has his own garage of
children's convertibles to chase them
down as well Oh
I want half you know as riveting as this
chase sequence is I can't feel it's
missing a certain something let's try it
with this let's ail wit Barnaby so he
feels it's time to unleash his evil army
on toy line after giving them all the
evil gas because it makes them evil er I
guess I have only toys toys cannot
protect us from anything as long as
there is one person within these walls
who can't believe in them who doesn't
believe in toys yeah well whatever that
means
there is one person who is never really
a child life made her grow up too fast
it must be you Lisa me you're always
saying I'm not a child and I guess maybe
you never have been are we saying it was
brought up twice throughout the entire
movie and even that it was pretty much
just glanced over and what's this about
being forced to grow up too fast we
never saw anything to indicate she grew
up too fast she still talks like a kid
acts like a kid what is she overcoming a
last minute ditch for a lazy writer to
slip in a stupid plot thread what do I
have to do believe in Toyland and all
that extension because she didn't before
you can see okay you know I'm here
signalization fortune cookie shit I'm
just gonna skip to the part where she
overcomes her obstacles that they forgot
to have written it
I believe me toy soldiers don't you see
I believe in you
I believe in you and all the toys yes
just look at the dignity of the toy
soldiers the restraint in their movement
the dignity in their March the fact that
those masks are clearly too big for any
of the actors wearing them sound the
trumpets call
will you knock it off I'm not doing a
Christmas carol parody okay okay what
happens if one of the producers actually
made a video for the parody like guests
if so I went to all the effort good it
was already made one she really wants to
see the project room forward really
loose on board oh yes she's really
passionate about it okay let me see what
video she said hmm god sakes what is
wrong with you
well she's in the video but she's tied
to a chair no no no this is how she gets
into character symbolic of how she's
breaking the bottoms of her performance
really quite beautiful if you come near
me again I'm calling the cops
Dodgers on you they're already looking
for me ah so the toy soldiers go to
fight the evil mutated Christmas trees
and sent them back to their bowling ball
of do
whoa this shit just got real
imagination nothing a new gun and
explosives it's all you need to save the
day
cry last big and let slip the pound
puppies of war
don't fire until you see the whites of
their eyes or the skin of their
obviously falling off masks no point yet
uncle Barnaby wha
see you at Thanksgiving
so Barnaby and his evil army are
defeated and they're banished out of
Toyland forever your evil against
Thailand you are hereby many forests of
the night forever I am only doing this
because I still think there's good in
you
so Mary and Jack finally get married
Lisa's the flower girl the whole
destroyed cookie economy thing never
comes into play and Lisa is finally sent
on her way home goodbye the toy master
will should have a nice trip deserved
you don't mind a few bumps hey it's
Santa cries now a grow bell fried rice
now Bhushan with ham on the one ton on
dumpling and Moo goo gai pan
people take the Milky Way all the way
hang on child and look out for the
shooting stars yes especially
considering how little wind there is
hundreds of feet up in the air
okay there's no excuse you should have
reshot that so lisa wakes up in our
house and wouldn't you know it it was
all just a dream
we must stay young and try to be good
and above all we must believe and I will
always have a Merry Christmas and
everything won't we always and always
always wait one more time I don't think
it was contrived enough
so one of the toy soldiers shoots her
the finger aiming gives her a salute and
they all live happily ever after
so that was babes in toyland 1986 is a
bad
okay that's us to the question but is it
fun to watch
well I certainly say yes it really can't
be and really lays on the cheesiness
it's a great film to watch if you're
just looking to laugh your brains out at
something so ridiculously silly and
personally I had a ball watching it so
if enjoyably bad movies are your thing
certainly check this one out
maybe you'll regret it but you'll have
fun regretting Alan the Steaua Critic I
remember excuse me
from laughing nobody news but Jesus I'm
so hot to cry when you teared every eyes
look just because I'm not doing a
Christmas Carol parent he doesn't mean
I'm not going to do some kind of
Christmas Perry hey come on look up yeah
tell you what why don't I let you pick
the next horrible Christmas movie
actually do it could be anything I think
the breach could be any of the
rankin/bass stuff the Greeks can be
killer snowman the Greek the Java to its
Hellmich weeks the creek damn it
I come from CIN CIN and Modena
Cincinnati the background of me Ohio
of all the baby
are you get offensive
you know maybe this isn't the best way
to get into character
you want to put